what i think is adorable is your kids
aren't bored of you
because they're watching old episodes of
parks and recreation
well you know i think they are i think
they are really bored of me i mean
they enjoy the men on that show they
really like the
they they like the male characters on
that show but it was really cool to go
back and watch it with them and i think
a lot of people watched parks and
a lot of comedy during this they went
back to the kind of their comfort
shows that they could depend on and i
heard from a lot of people
that parks was one of them which was so
awesome so cool
but then i heard you say that actually
when you were watching it suddenly
a lot of the plots mirror things that
are happening
yes there were there was a there's a
bunch of episodes where
the the town has to be shut down
because there's like a flu going around
and there's one episode where we have to
kind of do this fake
training of what would happen if you
know the entire country got bird flu
and of course my character just you know
loses her mind and
makes terrible decisions but when i was
watching it i was like wow this is
hitting close to home
this is a little too real
you